Stop the video for a bit and try to calculate
how much is 27 plus 1,
and then 27 plus 10.
Now let's think together.
This may have made it quite easy.
Perhaps you said, "If you add one,
the result will be the next highest number after 27.
If I add 1, it will become 28. "
We do this exercise,
to understand the meaning of the place or the position of the figure.
For example, for the number 27
we have 2 as tens, this is the place of the tenths,
and here we have 7 in place of the units.
You can imagine the number 27 as two decades,
behold, I have 2 groups of tenes here,
and then 7 units. Here, I have 7 units here.
And if I add 1,
this is another separate unit.
What will be left to me at last?
Behold, I have 2 tens,
2 tenths.
But the question is how many units do I have now?
1,2,3,4,5,6,7,8 units.
So the number will be 28.
This may not be a surprise to you,
but it's really useful to think
in terms of the value of the place or position of the figure,
because it will help you further in the study of mathematics.
Now let's do the same with 27 plus 10.
We have already said that 27 is 2 tens and 7 units,
but adding 10, this 1 is not in place of the units
and does not represent 1.
1 is now in place of the dozen.
That is, we have 1 tenth and 0 units.
So we have ...
The number 10 is just one tenth!
And what happens when you sum up the two numbers?
Now you have 1,2,3 tens,
you got 3 in the place of the dozen,
and you still have
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 units.
7 units.
Now watch out.
Here, when you add 1,
increase units by one, instead of units.
And here, adding 10, which is actually a dozen,
nothing increases in place of the units,
the increase is in the place of the tenths.